tell me a little bit about this fellow
who's sitting on your neither this is
Sigmund Freud who am the film is really
Graham Chapman's life story and
particularly his own search for
self-knowledge and and analyzing himself
and his chaotic life really so along the
way he calls in the services of Sigmund
Freud the founding father of
psychoanalysis to help him analyze one
of his crazy dreams and so Freud has his
own little scene in the film he's played
in a film by Cameron Diaz no less which
we were very pleased about we had to
record her down the line the only choice
oh yeah I was thinking whom time you
casting really who can we get to play
Freud and we thought Robert De Niro
Pacino then we thought no there's
something they just they don't fit for
its gravitas when we thought Cameron
Diaz really did that she delivers she
really did it so what was it like
working with Cameron Diaz as Freud was
down the line in Tampa Florida actually
was we had to direct her over Skype she
did it twice in her own voice which was
fine but then she suddenly said what did
she say she told us nine told us not to
say this on camera oh sorry oh he's a
bit stressed about it um she said I have
got this little man in my head that I've
been working on with this little voice
can I try and she came out with this
funny little man off Austrian accent
which was superb so Cameron Diaz play
Sigmund Freud as you do and who else can
we look forward to making an appearance
in this film well a gram himself we've
brought him back do you mean he's dead
he's dead any be in this film and he's
dead no I do but he's here he recorded
his autobiography lies orthography as an
audiobook can effectively that's what
ceded the concept that we could make an
animated film with him in scenes
performing and then bringing other
characters and other pythons to play
other roles sometimes themselves
sometimes his mum sometimes his dad so
the other pythons are now joining him
twenty years later in scenes are Terry
Jones playing his mum which he likes to
do
obviously Michael Palin playing his dad
John Cleese playing himself mostly in a
bit of David Frost and and other
characters and of course Terry Gilliam
also does an amazing job at playing a
number of different characters and which
was quite a surprise I believe that
Terry Gilliam has a very different role
than he normally would have in the
Python films and also the Python TV
froze as well in this doesn't he tell me
about that this is not a Monty Python
film what is it not it's not a Monty
Python film so we didn't really want to
use terry gilliam as an animator because
that would be too associated with Python
and and also we wanted really to this
film to be a showcase for young mostly
british new animators and different
styles so obviously we want to terry
gilliam to be involved so we we sent him
a script with a load of different
characters in and then we remember that
he never really played characters with
proper lines in the bond to python filty
generally just kind of grumps and plays
grotesques but he turned up and he
glowed his lines and he rehearsed and he
threw himself into it and we think we
found a new voiceover starring terry
gilliam if the older directing stuff you
know doesn't quite work out anymore as a
new job for him and what was it like
working with john cleese and Michael
Palin as well what were those guys like
it was great we had them we had Terry
Jones and Mike Palin and in in together
because they were too plain his mother
and father so they had doing a lot of
scenes together and so they were playing
two off each other very well and they're
great friends as well so the camaraderie
between the two of them is very very
very good and fact that Terry Jones is
also my dad you know directing him was
quite easy you know having a guy who's
directed life of brian and trying to
tell him what to do and he's your dad
bit tricky bit tricky but John please
John Cleese was playing himself mostly
through the film so you can't really
tell him you could you make that a bit
more like John Cleese please because so
actually we didn't do very much
direction at all in the performances
because they're all such pros and
they're so fantastic so we'll just let
them get on with it how does it work you
three guys directing together how do you
divvy up the director
royal duties we have a complicated
system anarcho scene because commune
based manifesto which we worked very
closely at that describes it actually
the honest answer is it's rather good
when if you had two directors they would
often disagree and you wouldn't be able
to resolve the issue but when there are
three it's a simple matter of two
against one so if one of us has one idea
and the other doesn't like it then we
don't fight it out between us we go to
the third and say what do you think and
then there's a casting vote so does
actually there's lots of time where
you're just trying to just like suck up
to one of the other directors just
forget your own way also it's quite cuz
me and Bill grew up together so and Jeff
reckons were quite competitive so he
used that you bet you don't have the
casting votes in the field when Jeff
first came on board okay came on board
he was a bit worried that we might just
gang up on him and then he seemed
realize that no we're just a bit too
competitive quite useful for me I see an
evil plan was hatched Shivan and even
Sigmund Freud yeah no he's not evil do
you want to work together again after
this no I do this we go that's a
separate there was a terrible experience
we had an awful time there and I thank
God it's over liar he's a liar oh and
the pipes no we had a wonderful time
we're definitely going to do something
else together and and the pipes this is
we should explain yes this is this is
grams kind of iconic prop I suppose his
best way to describe it which he says in
the film he realized could make him look
intelligent and as we're going to just
try now no I can't do it um so so so
we're you know we don't advocate smoking
it's a filthy habit great when you don't
use that bit everyone's going to think
what the hell are these guys doing
smoking a pipe but we're not smoking
we're just yo sticking it in our mail
Thank it is a bit addictive just having
something and you can join us as well
maybe make my own food out they love it
so it's a tribute to gram
going to go and what's next to you guys
we have another animated mental rock and
roll concept which we want to do which
is a we may be announcing in the next
few days any kind of clues at all well
there has to be something why go on then
Jesus Christ Superstar yeah we think
that that roads been tread over a lot so
we think we should reach read it again
I'm will Freud being this I'll most
definitely I think yeah one person you
could do very well with Freud's help
ease is Jesus Christ yeah oh no Freud's
lost his head have to go far been
decapitated
you